[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 tout de suite les titres
alors en effet va ouvrir ses portes et
ça se passera le samedi 13 mai à
Maisons-Alfort alors ça intéresse
évident tous les habitants de
l'Île-de-France mais évidemment les
habitants des Yvelines et vous pourrez
découvrir grâce à des animations des
démonstrations et à des rencontres des
multiples métiers de la gendarmerie on
va en parler dans quelques instants
[Musique]
une autre prise de 50 ans a mis au point
moveur moveur mover c'est un système de
réalité virtuelle sans casque utilisez
notamment pour soigner la dyslexie et
les résultats sont impressionnants on en
parlera également tout à l'heure et puis
comme chaque mercredi la sélection des
films qui sortent aujourd'hui sur les
écrans au menu du suspense de la comédie
aussi mais quoi voir et bien c'est la
sélection de Céline Charles et puis tout
de suite le temps qu'il fera demain
[Musique]
alors demain matin bah c'est nuageux
avec des températures vous le voyez qui
voisineront les 10 degrés donc ce ni
froid ni chaud et puis on passe à
l'après-midi et l'après-midi et ben il
pleut alors il pleut c'est pour certains
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle mais pour
beaucoup d'agriculteurs ça n'est une
bonne en plus elle est température
seront un peu plus clémentes 16 17
degrés vous le voyez dans la plupart des
régions de des Yvelines
[Musique]
et avec vous Régina on va passer aux
infos du jour et on va commencer par une
information alors le PSG
qui cherche un stade pourrait
s'installer dans les Yvelines
effectivement Patrice c'est l'une des
solutions évoquées un sondage a été
réalisé auprès des supporters du club un
questionnaire a été envoyé hier aux fans
et propose 4 solutions pour le futur
stade la première concerne une
rénovation majeure du Parc des Princes
la seconde le rachat du Stade de France
et les deux dernières options évoquent
la construction d'un nouveau stade soit
dans un rayon de 5 km du parc des
princes ou bien justement dans les
Yvelines autour de Poissy qui
accueillera justement à partir de cet
été le futur terrain d'entraînement du
PSG
peut-être le stade on verra bien il y a
en tout cas vous voyez des sondages qui
qui poussent dans cette solution on
continue toujours avec du sport avec du
tennis maintenant et il devrait faire
son grand retour au tournoi
d'Aix-en-Provence en difficulté depuis
le début de la saison le tennisman
ivinois Arthur hinderknech a confirmé
cette nouvelle sur les réseaux sociaux
il explique également sur ces réseaux
sociaux les raisons de son début de
saison poussifs depuis décembre il a
enchaîné le covid-19 la mononucléose et
la pub Alger à son retour de l'Open
Australie au total le saint-germain-nois
n'a remporté que 5 matchs depuis janvier
des résultats qui l'ont fait descendre
qui l'ont fait redescendre à la 80e
place mondiale
station aujourd'hui à Versailles tout à
fait plusieurs syndicats enseignants se
sont réunis place du marché Notre-Dame à
Versailles il dénonce le projet de
généralisation du du service national
universel snus souhaité par le chef de
l'État Emmanuel Macron en déplacement
sur le stand SNUI Sarah Eli la
secrétaire d'État chargée de la jeunesse
et du service national universel a été
accueilli par un concert de casserole si
je vous parle de chiffres du jour je
subord vous allez me dire 55 624 mais
5562 quoi il y a 55 624 c'est le nombre
de procès verbaux qui ont été dressés
sur l'année 2022 à Versailles alors cela
apparaît gros et pourtant d'après nos
confrères de l'hebdomadaire toutes les
nouvelles le nombre d'amandes aurait
diminué de 3,24 % par rapport à l'année
2021 alors le but n'est pas de dresser
le plus d'amandes mais de réduire les
stationnements abusifs et d'après les
propos de Jean-Pierre Laroche de Roussan
l'ajoint au maire de Versailles et la
recette globale pour 2022 s'élève après
de 1 million 300000 euros pour la ville
et puis il y en a qui revient un petit
peu cette covid le covid en reparle et
pour qu'on en reparle alors on en
reparle Patrice alors on espère qu'il ne
reviendra pas mais justement ce jeudi
démarre une campagne de vaccination de
rappel contre le covid 19 elle concerne
les personnes les plus fragiles et dès
l'automne une autre campagne de rappel
sera recommandée à un plus large public
merci beaucoup Régis relais et on va
parler avec vous nos premiers invités de
la gendarmerie de la gendarmerie couvre
ses portes je l'ai dit c'était le 13 mai
c'est ça
concerne évidemment toute
l'Île-de-France alors je vous présente
une major Christophe Carlier bonsoir
Patrice et vous êtes chef du centre
d'information et de recrutement de Paris
gendarmerie et chef d'escadron Aurore
Rigail vous êtes chef du bureau de
communication de la région gendarmerie
Île-de-France et c'est la preuve qui a
des femmes dans la gendarmerie il y a
des phrases effectivement tout à fait il
y a des femmes la gendarmerie féminisée
à hauteur de 20% 20% de femmes dans la
gendarmerie c'est de plus en plus oui
oui on a de plus en plus de candidats
féminines qui qui souhaitent rentrer en
gendarmerie justement le 13 le 13 mai ça
sera l'occasion de leur montrer les
différents métiers que elles peuvent
prétendre au sein de la gendarmerie
alors on va voir qu'il y a
des dizaines de métiers différents à
l'intérieur de la gendarmerie on va
parler dans un instant mais est-ce que
il y a une spécificité des femmes ou des
hommes ou est-ce que vous faites
exactement les mêmes tâches alors c'est
les femmes et les hommes peuvent faire
exactement les mêmes métiers les mêmes
tâches au sein de la gendarmerie en
choisissant des spécialités en fonction
de leurs évolutions de carrière ou de
leur souhaits d'affectation et autres
donc elle gendarmerie propose exactement
aux hommes et aux femmes les mêmes
perspectives de carrière
alors vous êtes chef d'escadron vous
êtes major c'est quoi un major c'est
du sous-officier d'accord donc moi je
suis rentré il y a quelques années dans
le corps des sous-officiers j'ai passé
un concours
comme ceux que nous passions
actuellement et j'ai pu gravir tous les
différents grades jusqu'à atteindre ce
grade de majeur d'accord et
c'est le un grade
d'hier d'une carrière d'officier qui
commence à lieutenant pour ci par
capitaine chef d'escadron il y en a
colonel colonel jusqu'au général donc
voilà c'est une carrière d'officier
alors par exemple
Christophe nous disiez vous aviez passé
un concours alors un concours de pour
être sous-officier directement tout à
fait alors c'est réservé à des à des
jeunes qui ont le baccalauréat qui ont
entre 18 et 35 ans et en fait après
cette inscrit sur le site de la
gendarmerie recrute.fr on va les
convoquer à des épreuves alors épreuves
d'admissibilité c'est une épreuve de
culture G et ensuite
en cas de réussite à cette épreuve d'un
miscivilité ils vont entrer en épreuve
d'admission où là ils vont avoir une
épreuve de sport un entretien avec un
jury et si les notes
et que la moralité également
ils vont intégrer une école de
gendarmerie poursuivre une formation en
école de gendarmerie
pour ma part moi j'ai je suis
directement rentrée au grade d'officier
en passant le concours qui est qui est
ouvert aux universitaires titulaire de
Master 2 d'accord donc il y a un
concours qui permet d'intégrer
directement
l'école des officiers de gendarmerie
nationale d'y suivre une scolarité de 2
ans et de sortir ensuite au grade de
lieutenant pour aller commander une
unité élémentaire sur le territoire
métropolitain ou en outre-mer j'ai des
escadron ça correspond à capitaine ou
pas non c'est le grade supérieur
c'est l'appellation gendarmerie j'aime
bien préciser des choses comme ça
qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé je peux
passer un peu de questions personnelles
mais c'est intéressant qu'est-ce qui
vous a poussé à choisir la gendarmerie
qui veut commencer moi
c'était très simple c'était vraiment
pour la diversité des missions
aujourd'hui
un jeune qui rentre en gendarmerie peut
donner une
[Musique]
semble que les gendarmes sont peut-être
mieux acceptés je sais pas pourquoi
peut-être parce que vous êtes plus dans
des dans des zones rurales aussi non
gendarmerie est très implantée donc la
gendarmerie
du territoire au contact de la
population dans beaucoup de zones
rurales mais pas que aussi au contact de
la population périurbaine elle est bien
souvent le dernier recours en tout cas
c'est un service ouvert 24 heures sur 24
7 jours sur 7 qui offre qui propose une
offre de sécurité mais également une
réponse à tout concitoyen qui vient
chercher une raison
je pose la même question que j'ai posé à
Christophe vous vous êtes dis donc au
Master 2 c'est ça et et vous êtes donc
une femme et vous dites voilà je
voudrais dire gendarme qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé ça
alors la multip publicité des
possibilités en fait en termes
d'évolution de carrière la gendarmerie
offre à peu près 300 métiers dans
lesquels on peut évoluer
que ce soit sur la partie dirigeante
donc moi j'ai choisi plutôt un métier
d'officier qui est plutôt dans la
direction le l'accompagnement et le
commandement de personnel voilà
exactement le management
et
cela dans 300 métiers dans autant de
spécialités sur tout le territoire
métropolitain et en outre-mer ce qui
offre quand même pour une carrière des
possibilités énormes notamment
en termes d'évolution en termes de de
possibilités de mobilité et de
changement également de d'un métier à
l'autre voilà alors une question de
structure alors vous êtes des des
officiers enfin des des gens de l'armée
enfin des soldats enfin vous déposer de
l'armée mais vous dépendez du ministère
de la Défense ou du ministère de
l'intérieur on sait plus maintenant
du ministère des armées donc nous avons
statut de militaire et
tout ce qui concerne l'emploi et mis à
la main du ministère de l'Intérieur
une sorte de regroupement un peu entre
la gendarmerie et la police il y a eu
des tensions par le passé il y a de
moins aujourd'hui je vous faire parler
de ça parce que c'est un sujet un peu
compliqué
vous faites cette journée portes
ouvertes donc ça veut dire je suppose
que il y a des besoins de recrutement il
y a des besoins de recrutement
effectivement les les comme dans
beaucoup d'administrations nous avons
des besoins de recrutement nous avons
besoin de
de montrer en fait à la jeunesse les
multiples perspectives de carrière tous
les métiers
qui existent en gendarmerie parce que
bien souvent l'image de la gendarmerie
se résume à
l'image d'un gendarme peut-être au bord
de la route ou en tout cas ce qui peut
être monté
ce en plus et ça c'est les gendarmes je
veux bonjour vous avez on va parler avec
vous tout à l'heure dans quelques
instants c'est la sécurité routière
c'est ce qu'on voit le plus souvent mais
il y a les brigades territoriales par
exemple brigade territoriale c'est quoi
une brigade territoriale c'est une
brigade qui est sur un accueil du public
et surtout qui assure une surveillance
de son territoire donc qui a compétence
sur une circonscription c'est un
ensemble de communes et les territoires
qui sont rattachés et qui assure la
prévention des atteintes au bien et aux
personnes sur ce territoire en lien avec
les élus et tous les acteurs du
territoire donc ce sont des personnels
que l'on voit très souvent également
alors le peloton de surveillance et
d'intervention ça c'est plus alors ça
c'est davantage une unité d'appui qui
vient au renfort et en appui de
l'abrigade territoriale donc plutôt
spécialisée dans l'intervention des
interventions
de fractions de hold-up de choses comme
ça
il y a des unités de police judiciaire
ça qui font des autres enquêtes je
suppose
les ah oui ça c'est assez nouveau je
pense lutte contre les attentes à
l'environnement et à la santé alors ce
n'est pas proprement nouveau mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a un focus un peu plus
poussé depuis les annonces du ministre
de l'intérieur mais il y a toujours eu
en fait des des gendarmes spécialisés
dans la la les atteintes à
l'environnement parce qu'on est quand
même sur une réglementation un peu plus
particulière en tout cas pousser et nous
sommes en train de développer le nombre
de ces enquêteurs qui sont en mesure de
relever les infractions et de poursuivre
les les contrevenants qui viendraient
apporter à ce moment parce qu'il y a de
nouvelles contrefortions notamment enfin
de nouvelles infraction contre contre
les atteintes à l'environnement il y a
une mission alors
c'est en outre-mer mais c'est un très
joli titre parce que c'est un titre un
peu ancien la gendarmerie prévoita là
c'est ça absolument alors c'est ce n'est
pas notre mère c'est la gendarmerie
alors ça peut être en outre-mer mais
c'est surtout sur les théâtres
d'opération extérieures en fait la
gendarmerie est présente partout où il
ne force militaire armée et déployée il
y a des forces de gendarmerie et c'est
la mission de la gendarmerie prévautale
d'accord donc ça c'est voilà alors on va
vite évidemment mais déjà on voit qu'il
y a des dizaines et des dizaines de
fonctions possibles et extrêmement
différente des unes des autres il y a
évidemment l'autre montagne ça on le
voit avec les hélicoptères souvent qui
qui viennent chercher
les gens qui sont perdus ou des gens qui
sont des spécialisés en secours aux
personnes les forces aériennes aussi
absolument nous avons des pilotes
d'hélicoptères des mécaniciens qui
travaillent au sein de la Force aérienne
de la gendarmerie pour assurer la
surveillance 3D mais également l'appui
aux unités terrain sur des recherches de
personnes sur des opérations diverses et
variées alors après je vais vite mais il
y a aussi assez nouveau ça la lutte
contre la cybercriminalité vous vous
avez des des jeunes spécialisés
là-dedans et puis alors plus classique
mais enfin c'est magnifique c'est
évidemment la Garde Républicaine un
cheval qui existe toujours il faut la
regarder quoi ça fait la garde
républicaine qui a deux missions la
mission de protocole et de cérémonial
notamment en accompagnement des des
palais nationaux des présidents des
autorités mais également à travers cela
surtout la sécurité en fait du président
de la République des personnalités des
présidents des États étrangers et des
palais nationaux
un mot pour ceux qui vont venir à
Maisons-Alfort le 13 mai pour rentrer
dans la gendarmerie alors évidemment il
y a des niveaux différents
il faut quoi il faut le bas il faut on
prend de recrute sans diplômes à bac + 5
euh de 17 ans à 35 ans avec la
nationalité française
il faut surtout tout le monde peut
trouver sa place au sein de la
gendarmerie l'idée c'est vraiment bien
se renseigner donc pour ça vous avez des
centres d'information et de recrutement
vous avez aussi cette journée du 13 mai
qui va permettre à ces jeunes de bien se
renseigner et en venant
des rencontres
bien se renseigner c'est quasiment être
certain de faire un métier qui
correspond vraiment à ce que l'on
recherche
on doit pas se rendre on doit pas se
tromper
on s'engage pour combien de temps quand
on s'engage en fait quand vous êtes
recruté vous partez à la limite d'âge de
votre grade donc c'est 28 ans 59 et 60
ans
un gendarme peut
ou s'il le souhaite
se s'orienter
on les accompagne d'ailleurs on a une
cellule de reconversion pour ça mais
l'idée c'est quand même de regarder
est-ce que vous avez eu peur de temps en
temps dans l'exercice de votre métier il
peut arriver dans l'exercice du métier
d'avoir effectivement des moments un
petit peu plus difficiles que d'autres
mais la plupart du temps on n'est pas
seul et la force du collectif on est
souvent à deux trois quand on est en
gendarmerie mobile on est au sein d'un
peu le ton cette force du collectif est
que bien souvent la peur est ressentie
après mais voilà le côté solidaire
[Musique]
des actions avec des des voilà mon petit
terroriste soit soit sur des sur des
terrains d'action très très difficile et
ben merci merci infiniment donc au
rappel 13 mai Maisons-Alfort c'est toute
la journée je crois 10h 17h
on va rester parce que on va aborder un
sujet
bonjour
vous êtes le PDG le fondateur de de ce
qu'elle importe c'est ça
exactement
et qui développe mauvais on dit alors
c'est une plateforme qu'on a créé alors
que tu utilises les technologies
immersive c'est vraiment notre
spécialité
immersive alors je dis en deux mots pour
voilà pour qu'on soit au courant cette
c'est la réalité virtuelle au service de
la santé
en schématisant un peu sachant
qu'effectivement nous on est aussi très
avancé sur les technologies de réalité
virtuelle sans casque ou le principe de
cette technologie là c'est que vous
allez au lieu de vous isoler dans un
casque avec une image 3D devant les yeux
on va projeter ces images sur des murs
et du coup on va libérer l'utilisateur
de d'un casque avec qui peut être
encombrant oxygène et on va lui mettre
des lunettes 3D de cinéma
ce qui fait qu'on va aussi être
compatible pour les enfants dès l'âge de
6 ans et ça nous ouvre justement un
potentiel sur Moover en particulier qui
est un outil de traitement des troubles
de l'apprentissage de l'apprentissage
notamment dyslexie notamment les
vous faites du gaming non oui
on va parler de concours de jeux vidéo
tout à l'heure
d'immersion justement au départ c'est ça
mais au départ c'est exactement ça on
est une bande de gamer c'est ce qu'elle
one clairement c'est à Montigny
et puis un jour on a une orthoptiste qui
nous appelle elle a tenté elle dit je
sais pas si ça se fait d'appeler une
société comme ça elle nous appelle elle
nous dit mais j'ai vu vos jeux j'ai
peut-être des idées et donc elle est
venu nous voir à venait de Rouen un
vendredi soir à 21h je me souviendrai
toujours on était avec Julien à mon
associé et puis là on a commencé à
phosphorer et imaginer effectivement des
jeux et finalement le jeu est important
parce que génère de la dopamine pour les
enfants en particulier et donc j'ai un
facteur de motivation supplémentaire
dans la thérapie et
la technologie qu'on avait développé qui
est sans casque son périphérique
permettait de mettre des interactions
simples mais efficaces
et
donc voilà on a travaillé ça avec
Charlotte Gibert donc orthoptiste à
Rouen qui est de qui est depuis à
rejoindre en tant que thérapeute
référente le projet et voilà et on a
créé ces jeux là on a créé des se
dérivés spécialisés
enfin spécialement conçu pour pour
régler enfin vous pour essayer de
d'améliorer le voilà des enfants qui
sont achetables dyslexie de
dysfonctionnements voilà exactement on
va traiter tous les troupes cognitifs au
sens large donc à la dyslexie dyspraxie
il y a aussi les troubles de l'attention
on a on a des thérapeutes qui traitent
les autistes aussi
tout ce qui est décisionnel troubles de
l'équilibre les personnes qu'on est
vertige et donc voilà c'est vrai qu'on a
vraiment créé une plateforme immersive
qui est une sorte de smartphone vraiment
grande taille du thérapeute sur lequel
on ajoute des applications et ces
applications vont tout et tout tout
avoir une fonction très spécifique pour
adresser voilà une certaine pathologie
de manière plus ou moins ludique en
fonction effectivement de ce qu'on va
faire il manque comment comment que une
personne atteinte d'une pathologie peut
utiliser ces technologies qu'elle passe
par un médecin ou en équipe que les
thérapeutes d'accord clairement
aujourd'hui on n'est pas du tout sur un
outil grand public on installe un écran
de 3 m de large projection 3 mètres de
large en 3D dans le cabinet du
thérapeute là on va en avoir deux lames
le premier donc qui est installé en
cours depuis le mois d'octobre et là on
en installé un Montfort-l'Amaury très
prochainement et les résultats sont très
prometteurs
au début même on en était même c'était
un peu on en rigole avec Charlotte aux
dépens on disait bon Charlotte tu as des
idées
résultats où on nous racontait quand
même des histoires un petit peu dignes
de Lourdes c'est à dire des gamins qui
avaient pas du tout à lire et qui se
retrouvent en intensif à avoir un déclic
en allez 5 6 séances et en suivant la
thérapie finalement en 6 mois plus tard
gagner le rallye lecture du collège
et on a une première histoire comme ça
une deuxième une troisième on l'insale
chez le thérapeute et tout c'est tout
nous disent ben ouais on a ce genre de
résultat en fait c'est une merveilleuse
histoire pour vous c'est génial non on
est parce que c'est très bien faire du
gaming c'était pas mais quand on est en
plus enfin quand on sait qu'on peut
avoir une utilité comme ça c'est vous
utilisez vous de la réalité virtuelle on
utilise
nos élèves gendarmes aux élèves
officiers on utilise effectivement les
Sirius game ou quelques choses qui peut
s'apparenter à la réalité augmentée
justement pour les faire travailler dans
des cas simulés etc sans forcément mis
en danger ou déploiements sur le terrain
oui mais vous continuez les autres
activités alors on a toujours un fonds
d'activité effectivement sur parce que
on est quand même expert maintenant
toutes ces technologies on existe depuis
2014 on travaille avec des gros
industriels
les États-Unis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce projet mouvoir a été construit sur la
base d'une technologie d'un produit
qu'on avait surtout dessiné aux salles
de jeu américaine à la base qui était du
jeu pur donc oui on a cette habitude le
produit gaming effectivement depuis la
face covid a clairement décliné et puis
aussi on focalise aussi nos activités
pour pour vraiment mettre notre cœur de
l'effort je dirais dans le déploiement
de mouvoir qui qui aide vraiment qui a
une vraie vocation je dirais à aider et
je dirais même philosophiquement on va
dire parce qu'on accuse beaucoup les
écrans notamment d'être responsables
notamment des problèmes de troubles de
la tension des enfants en particulier et
nous on essaie de réutiliser la
technologie encore un peu plus avancée
pour essayer de corriger ça
on est vraiment content de
combien vous êtes à 8 personnes à temps
plein et on a trois en 2014 on a une
petite société qui est autofinancée
aujourd'hui
et voilà et on a pu aussi la financer
parce que on a aussi des grands groupes
comme Renault en particulier qui nous
fait qui nous a beaucoup sollicité sur
sur de la des projets de R&D là on a
travaillé avec Dacia on a travaillé avec
EDF on a travaillé à un certain nombre
d'acteurs par notre expertise en fait et
là encore toujours avec un tout petit
peu de gamification dans les usages
parce que c'est vraiment une attente
globale finalement d'une génération qui
arrive sur avec les codes du gaming sur
le marché du travail qui a besoin
finalement de les retrouver dans tes si
peu je dirais
c'est une histoire magnifique chose qui
vous arrive et qui arrive grâce à vous
bon pourquoi ce qu'elle voit mon
portable alors ouais c'est pas le nom le
plus le plus facile à comprendre
quand on a créé la société en fait on
avait créé justement cet embryon de
moovers que vous avez pu voir tout à
l'heure avec ce portail on appelle à
l'échelle 1 parce qu'on est spécialiste
de l'échelle d'accord quand on va mettre
dans un monde virtuel un objet qui fait
un mètre vous pourriez le mesurer avec
un mètre bon il fera un mètre quand vous
allez mesurer c'est de là qui était venu
l'idée en fait le nom de la société
bravo merci beaucoup j'avais juste une
question pardon j'avais oublié de vous
demander j'avais envie de vous demander
parce que ça peut intéresser quand même
les gens qui voudraient être là est-ce
qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut avoir une
vie de de famille tout en étant
gendarmes ou est-ce que bien sûr tout à
fait il y a les forts possibles d'avoir
une vie de famille nous deux nous en
avons une
le gendarme en fait la plupart du temps
est logé par la gendarmerie et habite
sur son lieu de travail et l'hébergement
le logement accueille toute la famille
et adapté aux charges de famille donc
c'est même plutôt facilitant
je vous remercie de nous avoir présenté
alors évidemment mauvais et puis ces
journées du 13 mai Maisons-Alfort vous
faites évidemment des gestes de premier
urgence ou de premiers secours
de premiers secours
de premier secours et chaque jour cette
semaine et bon vous présente un geste de
premiers secours avec la croix blanche
78 et aujourd'hui c'est la position
latérale vous connaissez ça vous moi je
connais pas donc je vais regarder avec
très très très fortement la position
latérale de sécurité c'est Julien le roi
qui nous dit tout
[Musique]
dans cette séquence on va aborder la
conduite à tenir à avoir face à une
personne qui est inconsciente mais qui
respire là j'arrive près de du un jeune
qui est sur le sol je regarde
effectivement si il y a un saignement
important non et là je vais commencer
avec vérifier si il parle tu m'entends
sers-moi la main qui des yeux et là pas
de réaction la victime est donc
inconsciente il va falloir qu'on bascule
la tête en arrière pour libérer les
voies aériennes en fait la scolarité est
inconsciente elle est bien plus molle
que lorsqu'elle dort tellement molle
qu'effectivement la langue a tendance à
descendre le problématique c'est
qu'effectivement ce qui est dans son
ventre et très liquide ça peut sortir il
peut se mettre à vomir et là si il vomit
les sécrétions gastriques peuvent
descendre dans la gorge et comme il
respire ça va dans les poumons il va
mourir noyer dans son vomi donc il faut
le mettre sur le côté pour cela on
commence à retirer les lunettes pour
préserver le visage rassemblez les
jambes le bras qui est de notre côté on
va le mettre faire deux angles droits
vers le haut pour libérer l'articulation
faire la classe circulation sanguine se
fasse bien prendre la main opposée la
mettre contre son oreille ça va garder
la tête les voies aériennes libérées le
temps du retournement soulevez le genou
extérieur pour faire un bras de levier
et donc sans effort même si la victime
est plus lourde que nous en appuyant sur
le genou ça tourne tout seul ma main
bloquée je la retire en retenant son
coude j'enlève le masque je j'ouvre sa
bouche pour que les sécrétions
gastriques sanguines et salivaires
puissant d'aller et là je vais
stabiliser le bassin en mettant l'axe
genou hanche perpendiculaire au ventre
on va couvrir la victime avec un pull
une couverture de survie pour la
préserver donc des intempéries et
préserver sa température corporelle
on prévient les secours pour dire que la
victime est en position latérale de
sécurité et on va surveiller il faut
vérifier qu'il continue à ventiler
t'inquiète pas les secours vont arriver
les victimes qui entendent tout jusqu'à
l'hôpital donc on continue à leur parler
je vais mettre la main sur votre ventre
et là il faut qu'on puisse sentir les
mouvements du ventre pour s'assurer que
la victime respire et donc assurer la
surveillance jusqu'à l'arrivée des
secours
voilà la position latérale de sécurité
qui n'a plus aucun secret pour nous on
va parler dans un instant avec vous d'un
direjuna bonjour
vous êtes surtout l'organisateur du
tournoi des cités fantastiques en ado
ça veut dire vibration en japonais c'est
ça
et qui va avoir lieu
du 24 au 29 sur Skype
vous allez nous parler de ça parce que
évidemment beaucoup de jeunes là on
parlait de la réalité virtuelle vous
avez vu c'est intéressant qui peut être
utilisé pour la santé là on reste dans
le gaming dans le jeu dans la réalité
augmentée et la réalité augmentée là
avec le casque avec un casque mais qui
qui se projette dans la réalité donc qui
augmente la réalité on voit on se voit
les uns les autres et on augmente la
réalité très bien on va en parler dans
quelques instants Céline Charles bonsoir
alors vous avez fait la sélection des
films qu'il faut aller voir cette
semaine exactement des un thriller et
deux comédies voilà oui
cette semaine c'est vrai mais auparavant
on va s'intéresser à un garçon qui
s'appelle de Youri Kadia il y aurait
cadilla des
paraplégique et pourtant pongiste c'est
la preuve qu'on peut voilà on peut
surmonter son handicap et c'est la
preuve que même en situation de handicap
on peut prendre soin de soi c'est un
sujet que vous verrez dans cette
émission qu'on diffuse qui s'appelle les
yeux de Morgan qui est consacré aux
personnes atteintes de handicap et c'est
un sujet de Julien Leroy
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ma salle de bain c'est là
je me prépare tous les matins de l'autre
côté du miroir afin de faire tomber les
préjugés pour Yorick de haut niveau et
comédien parisien de 35 ans prendre soin
de soi est un rituel quotidien suite à
un accident de moto en 2010 l'homme est
devenu paraplégique malgré son handicap
avoir une bonne image de soirée pour lui
indispensable entre tient de la barbe
parfum et un petit secret beauté l'huile
de ricin pour coller le cheveu
amène le crâne cachez la calvitie et
puis en même temps essayer de donner un
petit volume en fait c'est mon regard à
moi qui me qui me préoccupe c'est ce que
moi ça me plaît si ça me plaît pas non
ça me plaira pas aux gens par contre si
ça me plaît bon bah ça va ça va du coup
influencer ma confiance en moi handicapé
à 78% Yorick ajal tient à valoriser ses
capacités physiques restantes en tirant
une force de sa paraplégie il décide de
ne pas subir sa vie et de conserver son
optimisme pour entreprendre ses nouveaux
projets
j'ai des potes qui se laissent aller qui
sortent pas de chez eux qui sont en mode
ouais c'est handicapé donc ça me sert de
mettre des godasses alors que j'ai pas
de sensations tu vois c'est et puis mes
pièces sont sur ma palette elle bouge
pas
[Applaudissements]
je la bloque je l'attends pas et mon
relevé les défis Henri Kadja à intégrer
l'équipe de France Handisport comme
pongiste depuis deux ans il s'entraîne
dans cette salle de Voisins le
bretonneux 4 fois par semaine même sur
le terrain le sportif tient à renvoyer
une bonne image de lui à son concurrent
[Musique]
mais le style et la façon dont on a
habillé renvoie quelque chose à
l'adversaire ça renvoie quelque chose au
regard extérieur c'est celui qui te
regarde à la caméra que celui le
spectateur le téléspectateur peu importe
il voit donc c'est comment tu te situes
on en revient à si tu t'apprécies toi si
tu l'aimes ce que tu portes si tu
l'aimes comme tu es si tu t'aimes les
gens t'aimeront de cette même manière là
tu vois yourica dial participe
actuellement à des tournois
internationaux pour espérer se qualifier
aux Jeux Olympiques 2024 il sera d'ici
un an si son vœu est exaucé une occasion
de faire bonne figure sur le plan
sportif et esthétique
apprendre à s'aimer apprendre à prendre
soin de soi c'est très important pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
pourtant pour tout le monde aussi et
puisqu'on parlait des yeux de Morgan il
se trouve que
Morgane Legrand qui présente cette
émission était venue ici et je l'avais
interviewé et justement elle est
atteinte de cécité et pourtant elle
l'aime comme elle va le reconter dans
cette extrait dessiner et courir vous
ayez décidé et vous aimez toujours
dessiner oui oui c'est un peu atypique
vous faites bien d'en parler mais
effectivement j'adorais dessiner des
portraits aux fusain je le fais un tout
petit peu moins parce que ça me demande
beaucoup de concentration et de fatigue
visuelle et que le potentiel visuel a
abaissé mais j'adore toujours tout ce
qui est artistique l'histoire de l'art
même en ne voyant plus ça me passionne
toujours vous savez de l'espace entre
les doigts c'est ça pour pour mesurer
la taille d'un visage ou dans le corps
je sais pas tout à fait oui tout à fait
pour bien mesurer l'espace sur la
feuille les proportions etc voilà il y a
des petites astuces bien pratiques comme
tel qu'il est alors c'est vrai que ça un
peu frustrant alors il existe des stylos
en relief que je n'ai pas encore testé
et sur le côté ne pas voir le dessin et
ben disons que je m'auto persuade je me
dis oh ça doit être réussi
voilà c'est un avantage tout à fait vous
faites aussi de la course à pied oui
vous aimez bien ça oui c'est vrai j'ai
couru en binôme j'ai eu cette cette
chance et c'est super alors intéressant
mais aussi comment immersif puisque les
réflexes l'environnement alors touchant
quand on ne voit pas et voilà ça
permettait aussi de retrouver de la
liberté et plein de sensations donc bien
sûr c'est super la course à pied
voilà c'était Morgane Legrand Nadir
Yulin le tournoi des cités fantastiques
en ado ado rappelez-nous ce que je
connais pas tous le japonais
ça veut dire vibration en japonais pour
un peu les aficionados qui ont joué à
une certaine époque ou qui joue encore à
un jeu très connu qui s'appelle Street
Fighter les personnages faisaient des
Hadoken en fait ils envoient des boules
d'énergie de vibrations même pour les
femmes
on les voit il y a pas en fait alors le
tournoi il est autour du Hado le Hado
c'est le premier sport d'équipe au monde
en réalité augmentée la réalité
augmentée c'est-à-dire qu'on se voit on
est tous ensemble d'ailleurs ces équipes
de trois contre trois inclusifs
accessible aux personnes en situation de
handicapés
et en fait on a un casque et un capteur
de mouvement on est dans une arène où
disons qu'il y a des il y a des capteurs
répond un petit peu partout et en fait
dès qu'on fait un mouvement on génère
une boule d'énergie comme un kamehameha
dans Dragon Ball Z en gros c'est une
savante combinaison entre Dragon Ball Z
et une balle au prisonniers et donc on
envoie une boule d'énergie ou alors on
fabrique en réalité augmentée donc comme
on holographique comme un hologramme un
bouclier comme dans Black Panther afin
de contrer les boules d'énergie qui
viennent de l'équipe adverse on fabrique
des boucliers pour son équipe on se joue
comme du squatch en match très intense
donc des manches très courts d'une
minute 30
c'est très physique c'est très sportif
il y a beaucoup de sportifs qui viennent
jouer et qui participent au tournoi des
adultes et des et des et des plus jeunes
à chaque fois ils sont très étonnés de
l'intensité du jeu et donc c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est à dire que c'est
une combinaison entre le développement
du jeu d'un eSport
physiologique absolument c'est vraiment
dans dans le physique avec et avec tout
ce que ça amène dans le côté innovation
quel âge les joueurs à partir de 7 ans
on fait des combinés on fait souvent des
nous le tournant on le règle entre 7 et
11 ans 11-15 ans 15 ans et demi
on a fait aussi des des tournois
plus amicaux avec
intergénérationnel avec les seniors et
les plus jeunes et ça marche très bien
ça marche très bien et même les parents
viennent on fait des des petites manches
un peu
amicales comme ça où les parents peuvent
jouer avec les enfants ou face aux
enfants ce qui est intéressant c'est
aussi que on n'est pas contraint par une
imitation physique c'est pas parce qu'on
est un grand gaillard qu'on va gagner on
va gagner
l'année dernière il y avait trois jeunes
filles qui ont qui qui ont remporté face
une équipe de de trois jeunes qui
étaient très fort mais peut-être qu'ils
aient ils se croyaient un peu trop
incroyable un peu plus fort que ce qui
n'était et la vivacité c'est
l'intelligence la stratégie de jeu en
équipe l'esprit d'équipe aussi a fait
que les les trois jeunes filles qui
étaient beaucoup plus menu on remporté
le remporté on remporté on remporté le
match tout à fait alors ça commence le
24 et donc on court après il y a oui la
vernis
et la finale et finalement le 29
absolument attrape la salle
Jean-Baptiste
à chaque fois des équipes qui se
qualifient tout à fait il y a des dans
chaque ville on va dans chaque ville et
on permet donc aux participants de créer
leurs équipes donc souvent en plus ils
prennent des noms d'équipe de mangas
c'est festif quoi très fun et du coup
chaque dans chaque ville il y a une
partie des équipes qui sont qualifiées
et à la fin on a la finale qui se qui se
joue donc dans une ville cette année
cette trappe qui nous fait le plaisir de
revenir la finale et l'encours nous a
fait le plaisir de nous accueillir je
dois dire que on a de la chance que les
villes à Skype la verrière Maurepas et
l'oncle trappes ont joué le jeu de
l'innovation du eSport et m'ont fait
confiance j'ai fait ma série
et donc il y a alors il y a évidemment
le gaming d'abord je voulais dire de
choses c'est la première c'est que vous
êtes labellisé olympique culturel par le
comité Paris 2024 absolument on a eu
cette chance là c'est important tout à
fait on a eu cette chance là en fait
quand on a lancé au début de manière
totalement neutre indépendante sans rien
justement les villes de Sky ont joué le
jeu ils m'ont fait confiance ça a bien
marché et derrière on a eu on a eu cette
reconnaissance avec des soutiens de la
région Île-de-France et une
certification de labellisation
Olympiades culturelle et du coup le
tourment maintenant le temps fort il y a
un temps fort qui commence toujours par
Skype et après il y a un déploiement un
peu dans toute la France on l'a fait
jusque Marseille absolument retourner à
Marseille la Paris 18e Paris 19e de
Pierrefitte pas voilà
partout mais c'est vous qui l'avez créé
c'est nous qui avons créé ce tournoi et
le but en fait
ma vocation en tant que cinéaste déjà
j'avais la curiosité toujours comme
fidèle compagnon et étant étant vraiment
impliqué dans mon quartier que ce soit
le bois de l'étang trap et l'encours et
les autres quartiers disons des environs
c'était de créer du capital culturel et
pour créer du capital culturel j'ai bien
j'ai bien senti que la fracture
numérique s'imposait qu'il y avait une
forme de jet lag c'est parce que vous
dites d'autres notre mission c'est
justement de de fracturer la fracture de
fracture numérique absolument c'est à
dire que
c'est un peu on a lancé d'abord les
cités fantastiques qui a un parcours en
réalité virtuelle ou le but c'est de
s'alphabétiser sur les technologies
d'avenir vous venez et vous découvrez ce
que c'est que la réalité virtuelle créer
des métamont ce que c'est que la réalité
augmentée ce que c'est que
l'holographique distinguée travailler et
j'ai très vite compris que si vous
voulez il y a 10 ans si je vous disais
que je vous avais envoyé un film sur
votre iPhone c'est bon et là le temps se
rétrécit le temps se rétrécit on le voit
encore plus avec lia avec l'intelligence
artificielle donc en fait les temps de
compression et des et d'évolution et
d'innovation et vont plus vite et il y a
un problème c'est quand on reste comme
comme on va d'ici à Los Angeles il y a
un jet lac de 9h bah là il va il y a un
jet lac technologique qui se met en
place et nous on s'est dit on va
fracturer voilà on peut pas mettre de
côté des populations et ça marche ce qui
nous intéressait dans le tournoi des
cités fantastique c'était en plus du
eSport en plus du côté futuriste de ce
sport là en plus il y a un challenge
c'est à dire qu'on peut on peut inciter
des talents puisque il y a les
championnats du monde à Tokyo il y a
120000 dollars de prize monnaie à Tokyo
il y a les championnats de France à la
Japan Expo mais en plus de ça quand les
jeunes viennent jouer on pique leur
imaginaire et c'est là où on fabrique du
Canada c'est aussi des dés d'éveiller
des absolument
c'est les deux missions
absolument mais bravo
et en plus vous en parlez très très bien
moi je joue
honnêtement je suis pas je m'entraîne
pas assez je me suis trop penché sur le
terrain voilà mais je suis intéressé par
par même à terme pouvoir développer nos
propres technologies avec des jeux qui
ont des référents aussi culturels c'est
à dire que c'était important de
comprendre cette technologie de
comprendre que derrière il y a de la
création artistique est possible mais il
y a également du business il y a de
l'entrepreneuriat et ça les jeunes qui
viennent participer on essaie toujours
d'aller toucher sur ça c'est à dire que
demain tu peux à partir où tu comprends
une interface de réalité augmentée ou de
réalité virtuelle faut pas se faire
intimider par les mots le mot c'est de
la langue française aussi de la langue
anglaise c'est tout et derrière les mots
et ben en fait il y a des il y a des
séquences à comprendre et c'est faisable
c'est accessible et il y a plein de
choses à déployer que ce soit on l'a vu
tout à l'heure dans la santé comme ce
soit dans l'univers de l'éducation que
ce soit dans l'univers du tourisme en
fait dans l'univers du cinéma qui est
mon univers de prédilection mais en tous
les cas il y a plein d'éléments à
développer et qui sont aujourd'hui
accessibles et à l'intersection de tout
cela aujourd'hui on a l'intelligence
artificielle la réalité augmentée la
réalité virtuelle les gens le monde qui
arrive ils peuvent son emparé ils
doivent s'en emparer je pense que cette
image virtuelle tout ça tout ça vous
passionne absolument absolument c'est un
passionne et en même temps pour moi ça
peut être aussi
des leviers des tremplins parce qu'il y
a il y a parfois on veut créer en tant
qu'artiste assez librement et il y a des
outils comme ça qui viennent et qui nous
permettent de scinder des de rapprocher
des des corps de métiers et du coup en
tant créatif des populations
ça absolument et c'est absolument
favorable c'est un lien social aussi
quoi tout à fait on a été voir quelques
enfants qui ont essayé
le ado on va regarder la réaction au
pied on va parler après
c'était
amusé
parce que quand il achète des boules il
est lancé dans le vide le fait de lancer
des boules sur nos adversaires et
comment les lancer j'ai trouvé que
c'était bien là c'est pas le personnage
qu'on a dans le jeu c'est nous le
personnage du coup bah j'ai aimé ce fait
et en fait là tout de suite si vous
voulez l'interface quand je vous mets le
casque vous voyez le terrain dans lequel
vous êtes vous voyez vos coéquipiers
sauf qu'on ajoute des couches un peu
comme Pokémon vous voyez un Pokémon dans
la rue mais là on voit des couches on
voit son bouclier on voit et il y a une
interface un peu de jeux vidéo et sauf
que vous êtes le player vous êtes le
joueur et vous êtes acteur du jeu
réellement physiquement dans vos
mouvements et donc
c'est pour ça que c'est passionnant
parce que on est dans c'est pas la
société de demain c'est déjà la société
d'aujourd'hui
mais mais qui peut-être très perturbo
pour certains très changeante par
rapport à ce qu'on a connu enfin
on est là pour ça pour c'est venez comme
bien par le jeu aussi d'apprendre enfin
de pénétrer dans cette société qui va
qui va être la nôtre merci merci
donc je rappelle à 24 24 29 ça commence
à Élancourt ça finit à tram les finales
final attrape le 29 l'inauguration
parce qu'en plus le le match donc les
matchs se jouent en live et dans dans
toute l'installation qu'on a les matchs
sont projetés sur un écran géant et donc
sur l'écran géant vous voyez la même
chose que ce que les les joueurs voient
c'est-à-dire vous voyez les la réalité
augmentée vous voyez les hologrammes
vous encourager et vous ont les gens
encouragent leur équipe les conseils un
peu vraiment on est un peu comme dans un
finalement dans un match de boxe ou un
match de basket ou de foot et d'ailleurs
moi je trouve que c'est très bien le
foot c'est formidable mais mais l'idée
aussi c'était de de pousser les jeunes
vers des des nouveaux sports qui
existent sur lesquels on sait qu'on
Île-de-France est un des viviers de
talents mondiaux pour le foot et moi je
pense que ça peut être un demain un
vivier de talon aussi pour les ados et
le eSport de manière générale
le sport est un sport après
ce qui est bien c'est on a un versant
physique et c'est ça aussi qui nous a
permis d'avoir la labellisation
Olympiades culturelle c'est à dire qu'on
était vraiment singulier général
merci
Charles qui vous avez fait la sélection
des films il y a de nombreux films qui
sortent cette semaine vous avez
sélectionné trois donc on commence
peut-être par un thriller et oui tout à
fait il s'agit de misanthrope de Damian
zephrone alors rien à voir avec la pièce
de Molière l'histoire se concentre ici
sur Eleanor Falco une policière à la
psychologie très instable qui collabore
avec le FBI pour appréhender un tireur
fou qui multiplie les massacres aux
États-Unis c'est shinyn Woodley qui
l'interprète qui interprète l'héroïne et
elle partage la fiche avec Ben
Mendelssohn en chef chevronné du FBI
regardez il y a 29 victimes
chacun de ces tirs a fait mouches pas de
douille
par un seul cheveu ou la moindre
empreinte
il ne veut pas mourir et il ne veut
surtout pas être retrouvé nous allons le
décevoir
je vais bosser pour le FBI
le FBI n'a pas voulu tout l'évaluation
psychologique vous avez échouer
agressive addictive et antisocial c'est
le profil des personnes comme
emprisonnent pas qu'on engagement je
pense que vous avez de l'instinct
transformez-le en carburant pour
alimenter de nouvelles théories tout de
suite
un thriller policier plein de tension
qui s'est renouvelé le genre le
réalisateur en profite d'ailleurs pour
dénoncer les violences systémiques qui
gangrènent l'Amérique il est question
par exemple de législation autour du
port d'armes alors autre rendez-vous
c'est une comédie qui est signée Andrea
Bescond et Éric métayer qui on doit le
fameux le fabuleux les chatouilles qui
est beaucoup touché il s'appelle le
nouveau s'appelle quand tu seras grand
et oui voilà il est réalisateurs
reviennent et nous plonge dans le
quotidien cette fois-ci d'un EHPAD qui
se retrouve obligé d'accueillir une
classe d'enfants en panne de cantine
alors à cause de cette cohabitation
forcer les habitudes forcément des uns
et des autres vont se retrouver
bouleversées pour le meilleur comme pour
le pire et au fil du temps les tensions
du début vont donner lieu à des
rencontres touchantes les liens entre
générations vont venir déjouer un
sentiment de solitude pesant comme on
peut le savoir chez les pensionnaires et
les enfants réconforts bienveillants ces
générosité humaine vont côtoyer la
violence institutionnelle et l'isolement
le tout bordé d'humour et de tendresse
on regarde un extrait
on s'en fout de moi
[Musique]
c'est une chance de les avoir
encore plus heureux il suffit de vouloir
et on termine
c'était une pièce de théâtre avec Éric
métayer
le défi
le premier film du château il a été
absolument formidable
le troisième et dernier film qui est
votre choix c'est une comédie qui fait
un peu peur et dans laquelle on peut
retrouver Joachim Phoenix tout à fait je
vous préviens ce film est un petit peu
spécial Harry Aster nous plonge dans un
trip drôle et hallucinatoire où l'on
suit les aventures de Bow was Herman un
homme paranoïaque et angoissé interprété
justement par Joachim Phoenix cet homme
perturbé et associal n'a qu'une seule
personne dans sa vie c'est sa mère qu'il
va tenter désespérément de rejoindre
tout au long du film mais c'est sans
compter sur du multiple catastrophes
burlesques qui vont venir perturber sa
quête il va se retrouver renverser
poignardée accusé juger et j'en passe
une présentation un peu chaotique et
surtout très métaphorique de son esprit
et du monde absurde dans lequel nous
évoluons
et puis on termine avec le cinéma avec
un film alors beaucoup plus classique
c'est le c'est le coup de cœur de du
d'un autre réalisateur qui s'appelle
gothibara qui est versaillé et qui va
nous parler bah oui d'un film culte
c'est le kit de Charlie Chaplin
[Musique]
je vais vous parler aujourd'hui du film
The Kid de Charlie Chaplin
connu sur le nom de chat Spencer Chaplin
il a été réalisé en 1921 donc par lui il
a été producteur également il a été
interprète du film
on peut parler ici d'une comédie
américaine mais aussi d'un drame
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu'on
part sur une histoire qui raconte la vie
d'une femme
qui n'arrive plus à faire à vivre elle
et son enfant du coup elle va décider
tout simplement d'abandonner cette
enfant
ne sachant que faire et du coup chaque
Chaplin va tomber sur cet enfant il faut
pas oublier que je règle régulièrement
le rôle du vagabond le vagabond qui n'a
pas de sous qui essaye de se battre pour
vivre pour avoir un toit pour avoir à
manger et un travail
il va concrètement se créer une relation
entre cet enfant et Charlie Chaplin
[Musique]
il faut savoir que Charlie Chaplin du
coup va lui apprendre tout ça toute la
vie il va lui apprendre
comment ça se passe quand quelqu'un nous
marche dessus sur les pieds comment
travailler comment
se battre pour avoir à manger le soir il
va lui apprendre la vie de façon tout
simplement pure et naturel
on a Jacky kugam qui joue le rôle de
l'enfant
de façon juste merveilleuse
touchante émouvante
on va dire même pure et avec
tout simplement enfin ancré dans son
temps c'est à dire qu'à l'époque le
petit côté visage d'ange pur
on le voit on avait juste envie de lui
c'est le serrer dans les bras et Charlie
Chaplin va faire ce geste là va faire ce
geste de la compagnie tout au long de sa
vie et va avoir une véritable relation
père fils
voilà
chatine signera également la musique de
ce film qui va ajouter encore plus un
côté émouvant un côté touchant et ici ce
qu'on appelle une œuvre du 7e tout
simplement
ancré dans son temps en créant encore
aujourd'hui
toujours aussi mouvante toujours aussi
touchante et
il va réussir du coup une fois de plus à
nous donner beaucoup d'émotions tout
simplement avec sa part de muet
un film qui pourrait se résumer par deux
mots
tout simplement une larme et un sourire
[Musique]
très jolie formule de Gauthier
vous connaissez la petite fille
Un dîner presque français qu'on a pas
réussi à finir à faire d'ailleurs on a
fait juste quelques teaser ensemble
c'est de le reste à plat oui qui
j'entraîne une bonne relation et c'est
vrai que c'était sympa de l'avoir dans
mon premier projet c'était il y a il y a
plus de 10 ans quand j'ai vu ça ça m'a
fait penser
à toi Dolores mais aussi beaucoup merci
beaucoup
Céline Charles un petit coup d'oeil
avant de se quitter votre sur la météo
ça vous intéresse le temps qu'il va
faire demain on va regarder
[Musique]
alors voyez le matin c'est pas bon c'est
pas très gai je suis à peu près 10
degrés faut se couvrir un petit peu
quand même
enfin c'est nuageux et puis l'après-midi
l'après-midi il y a de la pluie et puis
certains disent c'est pas bien ils vont
prendre et c'est très bien parce qu'il a
pas assez plus pour les agriculteurs
donc c'est très bien qu'il pleuve un peu
et en plus fraces 17 degrés donc c'est
pas si mal voilà cette édition de cette
est terminée demain vous
retrouverez une nouvelle édition avec
Nadine rallès merci à tous et à très
vite
[Musique]